Argentina is a country famous for three things:
tango, soccer and… economic crises.
Although, the later one, that might change
sooner than expected…
Yes, dear viewer, we are talking again about
LITHIUM, “white gold”, the new oil, and
the stuff that batteries are made of. Lithium
is what powers your smartphone, your laptop
and (maybe) your electric car.
As we said in this other video, Argentina
is, alongside with Chile and Bolivia, one
of the three countries that make up the so-called
LITHIUM TRIANGLE. The area where between 60
and 80% of the world lithium reserves are
concentrated.
From these three countries, Argentina is getting
the biggest attention by international investors.
Yep, you heard that right, the biggest hedge
funds have their eyes on this country. And
this is a big surprise given that Argentina
used to be the bogeyman of finances, the problem
child of economics… and now, well, it’s
growing into a rock star.
So today’s question is… What happened
to this country which improved their image
in such a short time? Can they really become
the leader of this lithium race? And most
important of all… Can lithium turn Argentina
into a new Abu Dhabi?
Today, we’re going to answer all of these
questions… but, before we get started, let’s
take a look at the history.
ARGENTINA FIRST
In the last few years, Argentina had become
the bogeyman for hedge funds. Under the presidency
of CRISTINA FERNANDEZ DE KIRCHNER, Argentina’s
government did whatever they could to scare
away any foreign company who might want to
invest in the country.
When it comes to the mining and oil industry,
Kirchner made an interesting move. In 2008,
she passed a law against the repatriation
of capital. This means that if an Australian
mining company made a profit by extracting
oil or minerals on Argentinian soil, the government
wouldn’t allow the company to send that
money back to Australia. Kirchner’s goal
was to force these foreign companies to keep
the financial benefits of their mining in
the country.
Nevertheless, as you can imagine, the consequence
of this law was that most of the foreign companies
simply stopped doing business in the country.
At the end of the day, why would they, if
it was forbidden to enjoy the profits at home?
But… well, this was not enough, the real
turning point for Argentina came in the year
2012.
Repsol, the largest oil company in Spain,
in the year 1998 merged with the Argentine
YPF. For many years, this brand new company
was called REPSOL-YPF. But one day, Cristina
Fernandez de Kirchner, in a very Donald Trump-esq
fashion, said ‘Argentina first’… Hashtag,
MAKE ARGENTINA GREAT AGAIN?
‘Companies that stay here, even if their
shareholders are foreigners, are Argentinian
companies’
And now you might wonder… Well, what happened
next? Of course, Repsol pursued several lawsuits
with the government of Argentina. But this
was not the worst thing. The biggest problem
was that after being nationalized, Argentine
YPF reduced their oil production in half.
Argentina oil production extends decline as
rig activity slows
Yes, yes… I know what you are thinking…
What’s the connection between oil production
and being owned by private companies or the
government? In fact, there are several state-owned
oil companies that work really well. For example
there is ARAMCO: it is the biggest dinosaur
juice producer and, still, it is owned by
the Saudi Government.
The problem here is that, both in the oil,
and the mining industry, you need high-end
gear. And each company has different technologies
and patents. In other words, when YPF wanted
to drill their those oil beds of VACA MUERTA
(BAKA MUERTA), they needed to utilize a complicated
technology called FRACKING. And there are
only a few companies in the world that have
the machines and the skills to do this kind
of work.
This is why it is so common that different
oil companies create joint ventures to exploit
an oil bed. When Repsol left Argentina, YPF
lost a technology partner. And this is why
people say that Kirchner fought against those
bloody Spanish neoliberals… and ended up
partnering the American ones.
Chevron, YPF Sign $1.5 Billion Shale-Oil Deal
But… hold on just a second because this
is not the end of the story. The biggest issue
here is what happens when you take over a
company from one day to the other. Well, the
rest of the businessmen are going to be afraid
of you. And… good luck trying to convince
them to invest in your country.
Think about it, let’s Imagine you have an
oil or mining company… Would you really
dare set up a factory and a lot of facilities
in a place where government can just seize
all of it from you, just like that!? I doubt
it. And this, among other factors, is what
explains why Argentina today has such a big
crisis.
But, now Argentina has a new president called
MAURICIO MACRI (MAU RITHIO MAKRI) and… well...
the times, they are a’changing.
WHITE GOLD RUSH IN ARGENTINA
In December, 2015, Mauricio Macri took his
place in the Pink House (the Pink House is
the Argentinian White House). He found a country
in the middle of a bankruptcy. Real inflation
was higher than 40%, dollars were sold on
the black market, and there was no company
willing to invest in the country. And all
of this, despite being one of the wealthiest
countries when it comes to natural resources.
This is why, since the very first moment,
Macri has tried to conduct a 180 degree shift
compared to what his predecessor did.
“Argentina's new government scraps mining
taxes”
In other words, Macri knows that lithium is
a peerless opportunity to repair the accounting
books. Of course, no one expects Argentina
to become the new Dubai overnight. But this
white gold is a huge windfall and that money
could cover the financial gaps of Argentina’s
budget without raising taxes or cutting costs.
And this explains laws like this one.
“Argentina signs mining deal to unify regulations,
attract investment”
In other words, from now on, mining multinationals
have an open door to the country. And… unlike
what happened with the Kirchner era, these
foreign companies can do whatever they want
with their profits. This is happening because
Macri has removed the anti-repatriation law.
If this was not enough, this legislation unifies
mining regulations all across the country.
This means the rules are the same no matter
where the lithium bed is. Further, the mining
companies will not have to pay any special
mining tax anymore.
Industry heavyweightsAlbemarle Corp., Soc.Quimica
y Minerade Chile SA, Eramet SA andJiangxi
Ganfeng Lithium Co.are among groups looking
at expanding or building new lithium operations
in Argentina
But hold on a second because things are not
quite as great as they look! Of course, lithium
is a great opportunity for Argentina. But,
as you know, having natural resources does
not mean your country is necessary wealthy.
Many Argentinians fear what they would called
“ a new Potosi (pot-o-see).” This means
they fear that the country would become flooded
with foreign companies that take the resources
and leave without bringing any money to Argentina.
So the question now becomes... What can Argentina
do to avoid such a catastrophe?
tHE REAL CHANCE OF ARGENTINA
As we said in a previous video, the real business
of lithium is not lithium itself but the added-value
products you can manufacture with it. At the
time when we recorded this video, a metric
ton of lithium had a market price of $9000.
Nevertheless, if we take that raw material
and turn it into mobile phone batteries, we
could get an income of between $1.5 and $5
million. Of course, this is a very rough estimation,
but it does help us understand something important.
But… hold on a moment because this is not
as simple as it looks!
Most of the lithium battery factories are
in countries like the US, Germany or, of course,
China. These three countries have a world-class
network of small companies that provide things
to the big manufacturing plants.
We are talking about logistics, semiconductors,
and so on. All of these things make the manufacturing
process cheaper and more efficient. But not
only that, this network effect is what attracts
the best engineers and skilled professionals
to these countries. This is the essential
if you want to create a high tech industry
in a country.
I mean, look, good luck trying to convince
a woman who lives in San Francisco and makes
a 6 figure salary to move to Rosario, Argentina,
and work in a factory. As you can imagine,
it’s pretty much impossible.
So now you might be wondering… What can
Macri do to industrialize his country?
Well, the first thing we have to keep in mind
is this: Silicon Valley was not created in
a day. Nevertheless, Argentina has a great
advantage over California… They can make
easy money by selling raw lithium.
Of course, this money can be used by the government
to boost their earnings, but it is also a
good opportunity to invest in universities
that will train those workers that might can
start those small companies you need in order
to get the big factories up and running.
Further, the Government can even co-finance
brand new businesses. This is actually the
formula that helped Israel become a technologic
capital. And so far, it seems that Macri is
committed to working this way.
But… wait a minute because there are some
dark clouds on the horizon. All these opportunities
Argentina has will disappear if Macri, or
whoever follows him, falls into the temptation
of destroying rule of law, and going back
to ultra-nationalism which would scare away
foreigners. And… it seems that Cristina
Fernandez de Kirchner wants to run for office
again…
So now it is your turn. Do you think Argentina
could restore the rule of law and become a
wealthy country thanks to lithium? Or are
we going to see a new nationalist backlash
and a new economic crisis? You can leave your
answer in the comment section below.
And, just before we go today, we’ve got
an important request from you! You might have
noticed that we rather like using rock music
in our videos, and we’d love to hear from
anyone who has a band and thinks their music
could be a good fit for us! We will of course
give credit to any music that we do use in
a video!
If you are interested? Please drop us an email
at INFO@VISUALPOLITIK.NET.
Also, don't forget to visit RECONSIDER MEDIA
podcast. They provided the vocals in this
episode that are not mine. And if you liked
this video, give us a thumbs up and… as
always, I see you next time.